CARRIE THARP: Hi.
Welcome to our session on
driving business transformation
in retail using AI.
I'm Carrie Tharp, and I lead
up retail for Google Cloud.
I'm excited to be
here today to chat
a little bit about the
state of AI in retail
and how Google Cloud is helping
implement AI in businesses,
like yours.
We'll also share a little
bit about our solutions
and then share some
best practices.
When you think about what's
going on in retail today,
the landscape is
certainly changing.
The pace of change
is accelerating
and COVID-19 has certainly
thrown a wrench in many plans.
What's more important
than ever is
the use of data in your
business to help unlock value,
whether that's changing
customer experiences
or improving
operational performance.
When you think about AI
and ML in your business,
it's a crucial component to the
future of retail strategies.
And choices that you may be
making today on your platforms
and capabilities can be a
big part of your performance
tomorrow.
We're very passionate about
driving the adoption of AI
and ML in retail.
Research shows that
there's certainly
value to using AI and
ML in your business.
It can help you make more
data driven decisions,
five times faster decision
making, and three times faster
to execution.
However, AI is really still seen
in its hype cycle, for retail.
We did some recent research in
the specialty and department
store space and found
that 60% of retailers
had 20 or more
pilots in progress.
But when you double clicked on
that, only 45% of those pilots
had been transition to full
implementation in production.
And then looking at those
that had been implemented,
retailers only
thought 40% of them
represented the high
value use cases.
So it's great to have a mix of
potentially low hanging fruit
opportunities.
But there is also
still a big opportunity
to go after where the
biggest value in retail is.
So what's holding people back?
In our discussions, we
find that data availability
continues to be an issue.
This really covers a whole
host of problems, everything
from data being
siloed and not being
able to get at all the different
combinations of customer
transaction product
and supply chain data,
to having issues with data
tagging and data modeling.
Second is technical talent.
Do you have enough
resources on your team
from a technology standpoint,
or the data and analytics team,
to really go after a lot of
these more complicated use
cases that take more
preparation of the data
and a deeper understanding
of the business.
Last as financial constraints.
So we all have kind
of scarce resources
when we think about the
capital and expense we're
able to deploy in
our businesses.
And so, do you have the
right amount of resources
to go after the opportunities
that you see ahead
of you, as a team?
With all the challenges of
implementing AI in retail,
it's more important than
ever to focus and prioritize.
We've done research to
understand where the value is
locked up in retail and have
found that the top 10 to 15 use
cases is actually where
most of the value lies,
out of hundreds of use
cases you could potentially
be thinking about working on.
Whether it's in food, drug,
and [? mass ?] or specialty
and department store,
you'll see, on this list,
that there's a couple of
key themes around inventory,
customer experience,
and store operations.
Google can join you in these
conversations of prioritization
to help you understand
what might be the best
opportunities for you
to go after short term
and in the longer term.
How Google can help,
from an ally perspective,
is in three key buckets.
First, we're building
industry specific solutions
that are pre-built and
ready-made to help accelerate
your digital transformation.
An example would be
vision product search.
You can plug-in this API
and allow your customers
to take pictures of
product and automatically
find it within your catalog.
Second is using
the building blocks
that we've already established.
One of the examples
here is Dialogflow.
Rather than trying to take on
natural language understanding
to create customer
care chat bots or voice
interaction with
your customers, you
can use Dialogflow
as a jump start
to creating those experiences.
And third is then just
using our platform
to custom build yourself.
There's a variety of
use cases that you
may feel are very
specific to your business
or don't leverage components
that already exist.
When we think about these
pre-built solutions,
we're focused in
three key areas.
First, is helping drive digital
and omni-channel growth.
So this is think of
everything that's
a part of driving
digital experience
and your e-commerce business.
Second is helping you become
a data centric, customer
driven retailer.
This is all of
the data platforms
and AI and ML that's
needed to help
you drive new personalization,
customized experiences,
and understand your product
and inventory data better.
Third is operational
performance improvement.
So this is helping you
unlock operational value
inside the P&L, whether
it's store operations
or reducing your costs
in your infrastructure.
First, let's talk
a little bit more
about driving digital and
omni-channel revenue growth.
One of the key priorities
here is helping
evolve product discovery.
When you think about
e-commerce today,
it's based on very
rigid structures
from site nav to using
a search text box.
And customer shopping journey
looks very different than that.
So we've been
focused on providing
solutions that help you evolve
that customer interaction.
All retailers are dealing
with several key trends.
So first is the changing
dynamics in shopping visits.
So COVID-19 has changed how
much retailers have customers
visiting their stores,
how big their basket
size is when they visit.
And so it's become more
important than ever
to provide new digital
discovery experiences.
Second, this environment
has certainly
made customer experience
a big priority.
Making sure that your customer
has all their expectations
met, whether or not they can
interact with an associate has
become critical.
And then personalization.
This has been a theme
in retail for years.
But it's now very
important to make
sure you're putting the right
product in front of a customer,
wherever their journey
may be taking place.
Our offerings are focused on
reducing friction for shoppers.
First is vision product search.
This is the capability
that I mentioned
that allows you to use visual
images to search your catalog.
So think of a grocery
store customer,
instead of building their lists
by writing it down or searching
for it on your app, they
could simply take pictures
and preload their shopping list.
Next is recommendations AI.
This is focused on
providing the best
personalized recommendations
for your shoppers
with a broad understanding
of their journey.
And last is search for retail.
This is bringing the
power of Google Search
directly to your
e-commerce websites.
When we think about
recommendations,
Google Cloud brings best in
class recommendations based
on our experience in
building recommendations
as a foundation for
several of our products
that are serving billions
of users worldwide.
Recommendations AI works
in three key steps.
First, you seamlessly integrate
your catalog and user events
data with Recommendations
AI through many of the tools
you're already using, like
merchant center, Google Tag
manager, Google Analytics
360, Google Cloud
Storage, and BigQuery, as
well as other data sources,
in most cases, without
having to write any code.
Once your data is in,
with a few clicks,
you can choose your model
type, define your objective,
and begin training your model.
In three to seven days,
the initial model training
and tuning will conclude.
And you'll see a visual
indicator in the dashboard
that the model is
ready to query.
You can then begin
serving recommendations
to your customers.
You can now also visually
preview the recommendations
being generated by the
model before you serve them
in production to make
sure that your setup has
been satisfactory.
The recommendations
are then constantly
improving and optimizing with
daily AI model refreshes.
Sephora is a customer that's
using our Recommendations AI.
Beauty is certainly a
space that recommendations
can be very important to
that purchase journey.
And they've seen an
increase in both their click
through rates, as well
as their conversion.
Next, let's talk a
little bit about being
a customer-centric
data driven retailer.
How can you use data
to effectively predict
customer needs and what
your demand might look like?
Demand forecasting is
an example of an area
that is critical to retail.
All the retailers
belabor their forecast,
trying to make sure
that they don't miss out
on revenue
opportunities, but also
make sure that they don't have
excess products sitting around.
This is a product
that we have that's
in our early access program.
We took on this space because
demand forecasting is still
a challenge for many
retailers today.
Retailers often have trouble
integrating new signals
and insights into
their forecasts.
They're often based on
static views of what
happened last year and
maybe some more advanced
statistical modeling.
But most retailers
see that there's
more opportunity in their
forecast versus where
they're sitting today.
There's also challenges
understanding
new products and
new categories, not
having enough information
to really understand
what the demand for
that product could be,
maybe making those decisions
based on intuition, gut,
or similar product performance.
And then last, many
forecasting models
don't really understand
local demand impact of things
like weather, consumer
behavior, and even now,
shelter in place orders.
Our Google demand forecasting
leverages our best
in class AI and ML and data
sets from across Google.
It's designed to integrate with
your current systems and does
not require [? written ?]
[? replace ?] of platforms that
your merchants and planners
may be using today.
Explainable AI then
helps you better post
forecast review, where
you're getting performance,
and what's really a signal
inside your forecast.
As of today, we've
developed ML algorithms
for demand forecasting that are
driving more accurate forecasts
for customers.
The solution allows retailers
to model future demand
for both long horizon
order planning, as well
as short horizon
use cases, to feed
into allocation, replenishment,
and planning systems.
We are now building out
the end to end solution
and partnering with a handful
of retailers in the early access
program to take this solution
from development to launch.
In addition to this
product type solution,
we are also working
with retailers
who are investing in
their own efforts,
in this space, using our AI
and ML platform offerings.
And finally, we also
work with an ecosystem
of partners in this space.
System integrators like
Accenture and Deloitte
and ISVs, like 09, who can
help you get results quickly
and realize value from your
data with integrated and out
of the box solutions.
One example of a
retailer that we're
working with in this space is
Carrefour, one of the largest
grocery retailers in France.
We've partnered with
them across a variety
of facets of their business.
But one very exciting
area is they've
[? stood up ?] an artificial
intelligence lab in Paris.
This is a place that their
Carrefour engineers partner
closely with our
Google experts to work
on solutions like optimizing
their product assortment.
It's very important,
as you guys know,
to have a deep
understanding of what's
most relevant at an
individual store location.
And so using our recommendations
and AI capabilities
to understand that assortment
tailored to the local store
level has been a great
value to Carrefour.
Next, let's talk a
little bit about driving
operational excellence.
Providing the best in
class customer care
and support through your call
centers and chats has always
been important, but has
become ever more important
in the times of
COVID-19, as call centers
have been overwhelmed with
all sorts of questions from,
do you have certain
inventory in stock?
And what are your
special shopping hours?
Like all organizations,
retailers
are facing a revolution
in customer care.
33% of retail
customers will consider
switching to a
different retailer,
if they've had a bad experience.
And estimates show that
over the next several years,
AI will be a large component
of providing service
to customers in call centers.
So it's important to
be thinking about how
you can leverage
artificial intelligence
and make impact
in your business.
Google Cloud's context
center AI solution
is built for this
new world, based
around conversational core that
understands human interaction
and incorporates the context.
At its core, this
virtual agent AI
handles incoming
calls or messages
and engages in natural
human-like dialogue
to handle common use
cases and flows, including
having to go off script.
When the call can't be
handled automatically,
it's passed to a human agent.
And the Agent Assist
AI steps into support
with the relevant content from
the knowledge base and context
about the user and
their situation.
The insights AI then
surfaces trends and analysis
to help the entire
system improve.
For retailers, the fact
that it's centralized
means you can apply
consistent intelligence
across every application
in the customer journey.
The biggest cost
savings can often
be found from deflecting voice
calls into your contact center.
But there's been
challenges in the past
because conversations
can meander
and [? IVR ?] trees may
not be able to adapt.
The inability to flex to
human conversation style
has also historically
limited the ability
to assist agents in real time.
Contact Center AI has the
ability to go off script,
so you can work outside
the predefined flow,
answering complex questions,
full of unexpected stops
and starts, word choices,
or implied meanings.
Contact Center AI
also has the ability
to handle multiple use
cases for your customers,
like taking a payment, updating
information, like a phone
number, giving them information
about store hours, which then
allows you to fully
automate routine tasks
and further deflect calls.
You can start with
an easy use case
and grow your adoption depending
on your organization's needs.
During COVID-19, for
example, many retailers
were faced with a deluge
of customer inquiries
specific to store timing
and special hours.
Our team offered up a rapid
response virtual agent
that could be set up in days
and take the volume of calls
off your busy agents, and
most importantly, make sure
that customers felt
supported through this period
of heightened anxiety.
Marks & Spencer is
one of the customers
we worked with in the
contact center space.
They work with our Partner
Develop to leverage Dialogflow
to help manage their
contact center interactions.
Marks & Spencer is one of the
best beloved retail brands
in the UK with over 30
million loyal customers.
And they had switchboards in
13 different store locations
across their store footprint.
And they were taking nine
million calls a year.
You can imagine that's a lot to
understand the different things
that customers may
be calling about,
specific to that store, but
also broader questions that can
be answered more effectively.
Using Dialogflow, they were
able to reduce that call volume
to the stores by 50% and route
more than 7 million calls
into the centralized
call center.
Now that we've talked more
about our solutions and some
of the challenges
that retailers have
using AI and ML
in their business,
I'd like to share a
little bit about some
of the best practices we see
across all the customers we're
working with.
First is understanding
your data for strategy,
making sure you're
thinking about your data
in a holistic platform based
approach that really expands
to meet all the needs you
have going forward, unlocking
those data silos and
bringing together the product
transaction, customer,
and supply chain data.
Second is AI is
truly a team sport.
Getting the value
out of AI can often
sit at the intersection between
several different stakeholders
in retail.
Whether it's the merchants,
the planners, or the marketers,
they may have a very different
view of where value sits
and how your brand should
really take on using AI.
Your CEO is often
your top advocate
to help bring the adoption
of AI and ML in the business.
Third is thinking about
how you can test for scale.
So given there are so
many different use cases
you could go after, it's a
best practice to use proof
of concepts to prove the
value to your leadership team,
and then get kind of
resources and more attention
to move forward with more
use cases, going forward.
It can give executives
and your stakeholders
a firm sense of what type
of value they can expect
and how they can be interacting
with data to drive value.
And then last is
going mainstream.
So thinking about how you can
better expose data and insights
to all of the users
within your organization,
thinking about tools like Looker
to help visualize and help
people understand what the
data might be telling them.
This will speed
your rate of change
and bring people along
the journey much faster.
This is kind of taking data
out of the rear view mirror
and putting it
into something that
directs the future
of your organization.
So now that we talked about
solutions, best practices,
I'm excited to see what you can
do to drive the adoption of AI
and ML in your business.
We have a variety of
resources available,
if you're interested
in learning more
about each of these solutions,
customer reference examples,
to go a little bit
deeper, as well as
partners that can help
you on your journey.
I'm excited for what
comes ahead in retail.
Data is at the center of
all digital transformations.
And there's great
things to come.